die eifel eine region mit vielerlei
gesichtern abenteuer und natur erholung
und action die route nach oben die
routen spitze nach hinten und jetzt fest
der über kopf fest wie das mit der
andere geht zeigt mir günter schmitz auf
dem schreiben
das gibt es in die fische haben wir also
vorrangig den hecht als die branche alle
haben wir auch die haben wir noch mehr
nachbesetzt weil sie auf der roten liste
stehen wenn man als besucher hierher
kommen kann man auch angeln hier sie
müssen wenn sie angemessen hier bei uns
einen gültigen bundes fischereischein
müssen sie vorzeigen und dann können sie
ihre frage erwerben
auch hier nur ein bisschen wasser und
schon geht die erholung los dass
schalkenmehrener maar einer von 13 mit
wasser gefüllten vulkan kegeln die augen
der eifel diese eigentümliche landschaft
durch vulkane geprägt fasziniert viele
touristen auf besondere weise auf
einigen germane darf man eben angeln
auch tretboot fahren oder im glasklaren
wasser wagen
überhaupt ist in der eifel jetzt aktiv
urlaub angesagt bestens ausgeschildert
die vielen fahr rad und wanderrouten
rund um die vulkane sehen
da geht es schon mal ordentlich rauf und
runter
also wissen richtig angetan es ist alles
so ursprünglich also und die die
natürlich so riesengroß so viel zu
romantisch so ursprünglich einfach als
da braucht man nicht mehr ans mittelmeer
fahren
etwas weiter südlich in einem engen tal
sind wir zu einer hausführung eingeladen
wir sind zu gast auf burg eltz die auf
einem hohen fels gebaut wurde
850 jahre alt ist die burg seit ihrer
erbauung ist sie im besitz der grafen zu
eltz der burgherr zeigt uns sein anwesen
wie viele generationen bewährt die 33
wenn man so zählt und ist es schon ein
zweiter gegeben ich habe es meinem sohn
schon übergeben und dann wollen wir mal
hoffen dass es noch mal 33 uhr weiter
geht's hier konnte ich denke dass diese
druck irgendwie nie richtig zerstört
wurde obwohl er die kriege auch hier
getobt haben naja das hat im
wesentlichen damit zu tun dass wir immer
älter familienmitglieder auch auf der
anderen seite hatten
die familie war so groß dann hat sie
wenn die franzosen kamen bei den
familienbetrieben franzosen und andere
banden kaiserlichen gedient und beide
haben dafür sorge tragen dass diese
brücken nicht zerstört wird
diplomatische geschick naja ist auch
nicht ganz billig muss ich sagen
normalerweise stehen die besucher bis
weit über die brücke schlange in zeiten
von corona ist es auch hier etwas
entspannter
der graf immer völlig nahbar besucher
können tatsächlich gefahr laufen mit
ihnen ins gespräch zu kommen
ja die haben jetzt gerade mal hinter uns
und hoffen in 250 jahre wieder reden
darüber reden und nicht über laufen sich
noch nicht vorstellen
für viele ist er der inbegriff einer
deutschen ritterburg es ist nicht
einfach nur sondern
diese beiden muss die unbedingt hierher
sie war die tomburg als sie kennt war
weil wir auch aus dem ausland kommen und
sie hat mir immer gesagt indira in
deutschland sind dann werde ich zum
essen duisburg besuchen
ja und heute sie war so aufgeregt zu
hochzeiten haben in der burg drei
familien mit ihren bediensteten gelebt
das waren dann manchmal bis zu 180
personen auf engstem raum
diese drei familien haben die sich mal
vertragen überhaupt nicht wie halt ein
solcher er stress förderer enger
wohnlicher zusammenhang halt einfach mit
sich bringt man sah sich sehr häufig und
und hat sich schon auch mal gegenseitig
erschlagen obwohl luxus gab es schon
auch nicht nur in den prunkräumen mit
edlen wandteppichen und einem bild von
lucas cranach dem älteren in den rund
100 zimmern gibt es immerhin 56 kamine
und 28 toiletten enge wendeltreppe
führen in die schlafgemächer der
herrschaften prächtige wand und academy
ersetzte damals die tapete die eltern
geschlafen in diesem sehr spät mit allen
ressourcen bett dass man gestiegen ist
im wahrsten sinne des wortes so nicht
was heute fällt so ein anwesen wie diese
brok in schuss zu halten keine einfache
lebensaufgabe traf es ein solches haus
zu erhalten er eine lust oder eine last
fast immer eine lust gelegentliche last
aber die lust überwiegt bei weitem
hotels ein stein gewordenes märchen
die eifel burgen große wälder und kleine
fachwerk dörfer wie monreal im
mittelalter eine von zwei bogen
beschützte siedlung eine alte tuchmacher
stadt am flüsschen elz gelegen
die mit viel aufwand restaurierten
fachwerkhäuser locken viele touristen an
in der kleinen örtlichen buchhandlung
findet der besucher wander und radkarten
oder auch reiseliteratur über die eifel
und wer sich für kunst handwerk
interessiert ist in der töpferei
goldrichtig und dann immer von unten
nach oben versuchen die wanderungen zu
drücken
das sagte und sah das keine schöne
stelle entsteht alge schweikert zeigt
gerne auf was man eine töpferscheibe
achten muss und so kann es dann aussehen
so jetzt aber mal ein bisschen tempo
motor fans können auf dem legendären
nürburgring so richtig was erleben noch
vergleichsweise gemütlich geht's in der
sportlounge zu virtuelle rennen spaß
gleich nebenan stinkt's heftig nach
gummi auf der kartbahn kann man es mal
so richtig krachen lassen
und dann das highlight rauf auf die
original grand-prix-strecke rennpiste
für lauda schumacher vettel und für mich
formel training für jedermann in
richtigen rennwagen echt abgefahren
barak angehören die wasserretter
die 17 männer und ich starten auf einem
teil der offiziellen grand prix strecke
vergessen die spiegel zu richten
adrenalin bis in die haarspitzen jetzt
volle konzentration bis zu 240
stundenkilometer schnell könnte der
wagen 15 runden später kein weltrekord
aber ich fand es ganz schnell geschafft
auf die jungs völlig begeistert hat sehr
viel spaß gemacht hätte länger gegen
könnten hohe kurvengeschwindigkeiten und
hohe bremsleistung jetzt mal wieder
runter vom gas durchschnaufen nun müssen
wir wieder zu fuß gehen in mendig
steigen wir in das größte lager berg der
erde
jetzt ist spannend 150 treppenstufen
führen in die tiefe es wird immer kälter
unten nur sieben grad selbst im
hochsommer
wir stehen mitten in einem uralten
lavastrom alles was jetzt hier hohlraum
ist wurde im laufe der jahrhunderte von
hand mit spitzhacke abgetragen
sie kennen bestimmt alle ein fußballfeld
stellen sie sich bitte mal 390
fußballfelder aneinander vor so groß war
die fläche hier in mendig unterhalt
mühlsteine und straßenpflaster wurden
aus dem basalt gemacht exportware in
alle welt ich habe bisher
tropfsteinhöhlen schon jede menge
gesehen aber das hier ist für mich etwas
ganz besonderes sowas habe ich noch
nicht gesehen ist gigantisch und immer
wieder diese mit wasser gefüllten mare
in gillenfeld sind gehörnte vierbeiner
zu hause
den stolzen herrn ziegenböcke der
familie holtmann und natürlich die 200
milchziegen die den rohstoff für
herrlichen sie gefangen
[Musik]
auf dem vulkan hof dreht sich alles um
die deutsche gegen siege zweimal am tag
kommen sie in den melkstand klaus der
sohn des hauses lässt nichts auf seine
tiere kommen ja das kann schon mal
passieren aber es sind ja zum glück
schöne leichte tiere und da tut dass da
nicht so schrecklich
eigentlich sind jetzt ja ganz
freundliche tiere schnell sind die unter
leergepumpt eine ziege gibt etwa
zweieinhalb bis drei liter am tag
und im jahr sind das dann ja 800 meter
konzentrieren
und daraus machen wir jetzt
ziegenfrischkäse in der ruf eigenen käse
schule
besucher können selbst mal ausprobieren
wie das mit der käseherstellung geht
milch erhitzen molke raus und ein
spezielles enzym rein gemacht
das kann ich ganz schlecht es unmengen
auf jeden fall kannst du dich jetzt
schon darauf freuen wenn du ihnen morgen
selber verzehren kannst er schmeckt
köstlich dir hier jetzt das ganze nur
noch kalt stellen und dann mitnehmen
deckel drauf man kann es mir gut
transportieren
im hofladen treffen wir touristen aus
der stuttgarter ecke die mit dem
wohnmobil unterwegs sind
sie besuchen das erste mal die eifel und
sind erstaunt was hier los ist also für
uns war es jetzt viel halt auch so in
der natur wissen wandern gewesen haben
und dabei und haben jetzt sehr die natur
eben genossen und die ruhe und die ruhe
genau es war ja schon ganz schön viel
los ist in der eifel auch jetzt super
zeiten sind wir sehr überrascht so
außerhalb der ferien ja da gerade auch
jeder campingplatzes ausgebucht und was
man hier alles für verschiedene
käsesorten probieren kann
hier haben wir verschiedene ziegenkäse
hier haben wir unsere eifel melden mit
waltz stimme dann die eifel würze mit
einer roten renn de
der jüngere und die ältere eifel würze
und wichtig ist allen akteurinnen von
unseren käse können sie mit essen
okay die chefin des hauses erzählt uns
dass ihr käse von sylt bis münchen
vertrieben wird sogar der
bundespräsident im schloss bellevue den
ziegenkäse aus der eifel
ich habe gedacht siegen käse ist streng
und er sich kräftig aber das ist nur ein
hauch von ziege und es sind ganz ganz
ganz feiner gebe
keine eifel tour ohne einen besuch im
kloster maria laach mit seiner berühmten
abteikirche dem wohl berühmtesten
bauwerke der alte romanische kirchen
baukunst vom feinsten zu entdecken gibt
es immer wieder neue details auch der
teufel wurde hier verewigt der teufel
steckt im detail
[Musik]
700.000 touristen im jahr kommen an den
laacher see um sich das imposante
benediktinerkloster anzusehen
im öffentlichen bereich der riesigen
klosteranlage eine gärtnerei in der man
die schönsten pflanzen kaufen kann
[Musik]
ziemlich ist halt einfach noch der
stille und ruhe und ist mein
lieblingsort
gleich nebenan ein hotel restaurant
kuchen und feine speisen mit kräutern
und gemüse aus eigenem anbau der mönche
preis nicht venedig china manche leben
und arbeiten hier handwerker und
künstler mönche ein ort zum innehalten
und mit dem blick auf den laacher see
ende dann auch unsere reise durch die
eifel ein landstrich der so viele
unterschiedliche erlebnisse bietet und
ganz viel raum
[Musik]